um yes i've seen the comments on a lot of the
videos yeah sometimes people um seem to be
they think i should be wearing some gold
trainers or something um but yeah look for me
obviously you grew up with me so you know sort
of what it was like for me growing up, growing up
there wasn't a lot of money there wasn't really
any money you know i couldn't, i never was able
to sort of go shopping buy clothes stuff like that
it was always hand-me-downs this kind of thing
and like if if i had money to buy food it would
have to be like whatever was cheap it's like
70p scotch egg from tesco's or like you know
halal fried chicken £1.99 this kind of thing
um so obviously for me growing up i never really
got into the habit of spending money because
there was never no money to spend really but as
you know i was very committed to making money
i always wanted to make a lot of money um and
then when i got my job in the city as a trader um
actually the amount of money people
was makingwas a lot more than i thought
was a lot of money like the amount of
money which was a lot of money to them
was a lot more than what i
had imagined basically and um
i realised 2 things like quite early in mycareer
which was -  1. these guys are making a lot
of money like really a lot of money and 2. most
of these guys have got no idea what they're doing
so like, i remember one guy like when
early in my career there was a guy trading
on my desk and he like rocked up at like 10am
we were supposed to start at 7am and the boss
asked him why why are you getting in this late
and he said last night was um Russian new year
he said he'd been out partying all nightand
this guy didn't know what he was doing but i
realised that there was a lot of guys didn't know
what they were doing and they're making a lot of
money and that made me realise if i really get my
head down i can figure out what's happening here
you know like i've spoken in my other videos about
how the predictions are wrong every single year so
i realised look these guys don't know what they're
doing, they're still making a lot of money if i can
figure out what's really happening here i can make
in a few years enough money to retire basically
and like i got my head down and just
devoted myself to like i want to figure out
what's happening in the economy? how to
be the best trader that there is basically
and i was just obsessed with that, that's all
i thought about, that's all i did every day
and um i was so obsessed with becoming the
best trader that i didn't really have time to think
about what to do with this money and like i sort
of put my head down for like two, three years and
by the time i looked up i was the top trader in
the bank and i'd made millions of pounds basically
and then it was just there and then suddenly like
i didn't even really, i came from being very poor
and not ever spending money and then by the
time i made money by the time i'd stopped
working out how to make money, i was already
reallyrich basically, rich enough to retire so
but as i've spoken about in some of my other
videos i madethe money by betting that the
global economy wasgoing to be terrible forever
so it was like a madsituation i was in right where
i'd made all thismoney & i never even started
spending moneyso i'm still living like an ordinary
person in terms of spending & yet suddenly i've
made millions of pounds by betting the world was
gonna be terrible forever you know what i mean
so then it was like by then it was enough money
to retire you know i mean and then i was sort of
thinking well if you've got enough money to retire
and you know that terrible things are going to
happen probably you need to retire and try and do
something at least say something you know even
if it's not going to work you have a responsibility
don't you, to try and say something so thenlike
i quit the job right and um i quit the jobbefore
i'd ever really started spending money butthen
when i quit the job then i didn't have noincome
you know what i mean so then suddenly
it was a weird situation where i had a lot
of money in the bank but i'd gone back into a
situation where like month to month i wasn't
having any money coming in, so it's kind of a
weird situation and um even though i knew that i
had made a lot of money it was um it's this
weird sort of insecure feeling when there's
nothing coming in like that was like, you know
what it was like when i was a kid and then um
i just um i just thought i'd go back
to like how life always was not like
don't get me wrong right i'm not eating scotch
eggs from tesco anymore, well i do sometimes
but um you know i like to travel and you know
sometimes i go to restaurants and you know
you know i eat when i need to eat, like i used
to skip meals now i don't have to do that but
for me like i suppose i became so interested in
economics and the economy that like that is what i
put my energy into you know what i mean and
also i know what it's like to not have money
it's it's [ __ ] to not have
money it's difficult and um
for me the most important thing about having
money is i don't need to worry about paying
a mortgage i don't need to worry about paying
the bills i don't need to worry about my kids
being poor like i was poor you know i mean for
me that's that's what i really want like i don'treally
need a gold chain and you know what i mean
pair of balenciaga's like for me i was never really
interested in that, don't get me wrong like ifyou
work your whole life to buy like a dream car then
go and buy it but for me it was never really about
that i just wanted to be a damn good trader and
and i was & also to just not have those
worriesthat my parents had & that i had
when i was a kid, so for me like that money
i can use it to bet on the markets i can use it to
to exercise my skill which is understanding
the economy and being a good trader but
the most important thing about it is it means
that i have the freedom to do this as my job
you know i don't get paid to do this, i do this
because i think it's important that people know
that the only way to make things better is to
deal with this problem of wealth inequality so
so yeah if people want to know why um i don't drive
a lamborghini in my videos it's um it's because um
nobody's paying me to make them
and um i don't need the lamborghini
for me look i'm just a regular guy i'm here for
the economics that's um yeah that's it you know
maybe if i start getting 100 million
views things will change but um we'll see
but poorer families will be forcedto lose
almost all their assetsincluding their home
we have a tax system which isvery
efficient at taxing ordinary working people
but very inefficient at taxing the super rich